CNBC reporting half of Americans avoid
the stock market more than half of
Americans 52% are currently not
investing in the stock market either by
buying individual stocks or mutual funds
or through a retirement account like a
401k or an IRA according to a recent
survey among the non investors surveyed
half of them 53% so they don't have the
money to invest and 21% said they don't
trust stock brokers or financial
advisors let's see that'd be 21% of 50
which is 10% of the population okay
what's worse is that bank rates survey
more than 1,000 adults may be
overestimating the percentage of
Americans investing in the stock market
a study from the Federal Reserve found
that only 13% of US households owned
stocks in 2013 down from 15% in 2010 so
I get a guy on Twitter fairly often
including today asking me why in the
world would you ever recommend mutual
funds you must be getting a kickback no
not getting a kickback wish I was I'd be
better off than I am give me an
opportunity to pay a lot more taxes this
week but I do have endorsed local
providers and in return for their me
endorsing them they do several things
for mutual funds they are not people
that work for me but they agree to take
care of small investors like single moms
and teenagers that don't have a lot to
invest a lot of brokers won't deal with
the small accounts because it's not
worth their time secondly they have to
approach investing with the heart of a
teacher not the heart of a Salesman
about 85 percent of the people in the
financial world are salespeople not
teachers and you want to stay away from
the salespeople you want to go to the
teacher and that's a spirit that's not a
position or a business card that's how
you feel when you meet with them are you
being taught or are you being sold if
you're being taught you got the right
guy the right gal to help you with your
decision about whatever financial
product that is including mutual funds
thirdly they have to agree to give you
investment that's our investment advice
consistent with what
you would hear here on the air or in
Financial Peace University or in one of
my books because why would I send you to
someone that would give you different
financial advice that's weird and be
inconsistent then you'd be mad at me
fourthly they pay us a fee but they
don't get the opportunity to pay us a
fee unless they do the other three
things they pay for the endorsement and
we have about 65 people on that team
that manage those relationships and make
sure those people those endorsed local
providers are taking care of you so the
reason I tell people to invest in the
stock market hasn't got anything to do
with money I make off of it because I
don't make a commission whether you
invest or whether you don't
it doesn't matter to me doesn't change
anything so why do I tell you to invest
in good growth stock mutual funds why
would I possibly do that when 50% of
Americans don't invest in the stock
market now we need to keep in mind that
half of that 50% or 25% of Americans
don't invest in the stock market because
are any money according to this survey I
think it's probably higher than that but
um we I personally invest in good growth
stock mutual funds why would I do
something and then that I think is good
and then not tell you that I think it's
good
that'd be pretty hypocritical and
inconsistent for me to do one kind of
investing and then tell you to do
something else
so I don't tell you to do things I don't
do but the first thing is you can't be
broke you got to get through your baby
steps you got to get out of debt you got
to have your emergency fund in place and
then you get to baby step four and you
start putting fifteen percent of your
income into retirement why at that point
what I recommend mutual funds the cells
carry stock market and all those crooks
and people on Wall Street you get people
carrying on like a beagle chasing a
rabbit it's unbelievable the reason is
that three times this week I've had
people call me in their 50s 60s and 70s
that had in excess of two million
dollars in their 401k to retire on and
guess what they did they made a
household income of 50 to 150 thousand
dollars in all three cases over a 15 20
30 year period of time invested heavily
in their 401k and good growth stock
mutual funds that had long track records
that's why I tell you to invest in
mutual funds because I want you to be a
multimillionaire
is it gonna be multi-millionaire if you
put $10 in there
no do I believe the stock market is
going to go down absolutely do I believe
the stock market is going to go up
absolutely which ones are going to do
today Dave I have no idea I am confident
enough that it's going to go up over the
long term that I have millions of
dollars invested in good growth stock
mutual funds personally and so if my
advice is bad I'm screwed - hello that's
how this works
so keep this in mind I mean this is how
it works now you know you know what
about the tech crash and what about the
2008 crash and what about the crash with
Bush and Obama in the oh yeah there's
always a crash but what about the
recovery you remember when the stock
market went from 13,000 to 6500 right as
Bush was leaving and Obama was coming in
that's what happened you remember back
oh wait and the world came to an inn and
everybody's running around like chicken
little handed out helmets this guy's
falling right and I keep telling folks
you don't get hurt on a roller coaster
unless you jump off keep buying keep
buying keep buying now it was a 6500
what if you had put in a million dollars
a 6500 if you happen to know where the
bottom was which I didn't know where the
bottom was so I just kept investing like
I always do i didn't put extra in but
what if just that day that you were
clairvoyant and you saw the bottom when
the whole world is caving in and it's
all over the news and congress is
predicting the end of the world and
they're too big to let them go bankrupt
we have to save everyone don't you
remember all that crap don't you
remember it drama queens okay so what if
in the middle of that you somehow decide
you were going to put a million dollars
in at 6,500 and that's March of Voe 9 I
believe it was if you put in a million
dollars there at that time then based on
the Dow Jones Industrial Average wean
6500 what would you have today does
anybody know anybody know what the Dow
Jones Industrial Average is today I'll
help you with that it's a little over
18,000 if it was 6500 before it's a
little over 18,000 now let me help you
with your sixth-grade math that's three
times bigger okay that means your
million dollars that you put in at the
bottom or the wall is coming to an end
would now be worth three million dollars
or if you put in a hundred thousand be
worth three hundred thousand if you put
in ten thousand be worth thirty thousand
your money would have tripled but no one
talks about that I always talk about all
the bad stuff
remember when houses went down how come
half of Americans quit didn't quit
buying houses houses went down in value
everybody's upside down we had to have a
heart program and of this program and
that program Washington had to come and
save us on the way towards thank you
Washington turns out houses go up in
value people kept buying them long term
track record past performance does not
indicate future yeah it does yeah it
does it's really only important testing
method that has any tangible reality to
it so that's why I invest in good growth
stock mutual funds and - I tell you -
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you